And the answer here is in some way surprising.
Although we have a 10 times improvement, we actually cannot handle an input that is much larger.
We can only handle an input where n is 33 or smaller,
and the way you can figure this out is as follows--
If the maximum input size we can handle is 30, then the number of time steps
this algorithm over here takes is 2³⁰  30², which is 966,367,641,600 time steps.
So already a rather powerful computer at work here I would presume.
What if we have an algorithm that is 10 times faster.
Now, 2³¹31²/10 is about 206 billion, 2³²32²/10=440 billions--that is still smaller than this
and 2³³33² is about 93 billion, so slightly smaller still than this one here.
If you increase it to 34, then this number here will become larger than this one over here.